my talk at the table this is for all the
book nerds here at the table which is us
and all your book nerds at home merriam
webster's dictionary adding 455 words
this month they include tbh which is an
abbreviation for to be honest i
struggled with that for a long time me
too um fluffernutter a sandwich uh with
butter and fluffernutter a sandwich with
peanut butter i said that right live on
tv and that's with peanut butter and
marshmallow cream between two slices of
white bread and then this one right here
i'm excited about dad bod a physique
regard uh difficult
all the dead bodies in the house give me
a round of applause how about all the
ladies who like it daddy we get it guys
we don't need to hide our gut anymore oh
my gosh
i walk around and i look two months
pregnant i'm gonna let it go now that is
not you
no but uh for all the bad boss fathers
that is him we made it all right we made
it into the dictionary the physique is
all here but here he's i think that yeah
yeah oh yeah we've learned the art of
tucking it in on tv i love a dad bot it
means i can eat whatever i want see that
is